I decided to focus on heart failure
because of the burden of this condition
so 5 million people in the United States
have heart failure it's actually the
leading cause of hospitalization among
medicare recipients number one cause of
readmission within 60 days of discharge
and the total cost of heart failure over
30 billion dollars per year many of us
in the room who are clinically active
understand the importance of early
readmissions and the pressure on health
systems to reduce these so this issue of
heart failure and heart failure
readmissions in particular is something
that's on everyone's radar screen right
now in developing strategies to reduce
heart failure readmissions has really
become a national priority so that these
are now publicly reported performance
measures and their financial penalties
for 30-day readmissions so
telemonitoring is a promising strategy
that can enable remote monitoring so
that clinicians can intervene early when
there's evidence of clinical
deterioration and the rationale for this
is that many patients with heart failure
may deteriorate over a period of days to
even weeks before requiring
hospitalization and so if only we had
some way to sort of monitor patients
status that might alert clinicians to
early signs and symptoms of
decompensation so that we could avert
the need for hospitalization or even
worse a death before hospitalization can
occur so to get a better handle on this
period of sort of subclinical
deterioration before hospitalization or
what's going on in that window that's
oftentimes invisible to us as clinicians
before patients come into the emergency
room ER to the hospital we did a case
control study I try to keep the
microphone near me as I sort of turn
around here but just let me know if you
can't hear me so day 0 is the day that
our case patients which are shown in the
upper line there with a triangular hatch
marks the case patients were
hospitalized for heart failure on day 0
and we matched these cases to control
patients based on weight and New York
Heart Association sex and we had daily
weights on these patients so this is
information on patients with heart
failure who are
weighing themselves on a daily basis has
came from a telemonitoring company so at
the beginning of the study 45 days you
see all the way to the far left there
were 45 days prior to the time of heart
failure hospitalization the weights on
these patients were very well matched
and then a few days before the heart
failure hospitalization happened in the
case patients you see that the weight
start to diverge and that the case
patients started to put on weight
somewhere between five and seven days
before hospitalization occurred and so
that kind of lended some credence to
this idea that there was a time period a
window where if only we knew about this
weight change and perhaps some other
symptoms that patients may be
experiencing that perhaps the physicians
could implement interventions to avert
that outcome of hospitalization so in
fact there have been a few studies to
look at this question you know ken
providing physicians with information
about patient's clinical status avert
hospitalization that there was a recent
meta-analysis that came out last summer
by the Cochrane group looking at
telephone support and telemonitoring
programs for patients with heart failure
and the authors of this review concluded
that in fact telemonitoring for patients
with heart failure is effective the last
row there shows you the effect for all
cause mortality so it was effective in
reducing all cause mortality with a
hazard ratio of point 66 and all cause
hospitalization the author's went on to
make comments about how patients found
this technology to be very acceptable
and adapted to use of this technology
easily but when we went through and
starting to look at some of the
individual studies that were included in
this meta-analysis we started to
understand that there were a number of
limitations so that many of these
studies were small most the vast
majority of the 25 studies included in
this meta-analysis had fewer than 250
subjects in fact over half of them had
fewer than a hundred almost all of them
were conducted at a single site and
oftentimes the investigators were
testing the effectiveness of what we
call homegrown interventions so the
investigators developed their own
telemonitoring intervention and then
we're the same people who were testing
the effectiveness which of course might
lead to some
there are many strategies to implement
telemonitoring this is really a
promising approach and sort of despite
the limitations of the evidence-based
telemonitoring is something which is
really taken off it's really captured
quite a market share it's being used in
a number of managed care organizations
and also in the VA as well so to kind of
assess this this question and really get
a better handle on you know ken
telemonitoring really improve outcomes
we conducted this clinical trial and our
primary hypothesis was it telemonitoring
will reduce the combined outcome of all
cause readmission and death over six
months so to be eligible for this study
patients had to be hospitalized for
heart failure in the past 30 days and we
selected patients who were recently
hospitalized because that's a
particularly vulnerable group so you
know once patients are hospitalized for
heart failure they have about a fifty
percent chance based on recent medicare
data for either being rehospitalization
we thought that we would have an
opportunity to do some good their
patients had to be at least 18 years of
age able to speak english or spanish
provide informed consent and they had to
have access to a reliable telephone line
not necessarily a landline it could be a
cell phone it could be a neighbor's
phone but they had to be able to make
these phone calls every day so we
established a recruitment network of
cardiology practices across the country
with particular attention to geographic
diversity but also racial and
socio-economic diversity so these were
all cardiology outpatient practices and
these practices were responsible for
screening and enrolling their own
patients into the study so these are the
cardiologists who are responsible for
taking care of the patients these aren't
you know third parties but these are the
patients doctors they had to review and
manage the information that was coming
in from the telemonitoring system on a
daily basis and in this way the
intervention was really firmly embedded
in real-world clinical practice so this
trial was really sort of a strategy
trial testing a strategy of providing
physicians with more information about
their patients and so the showed you
that there were many different companies
and devices to implement telemonitoring
the one that we selected was developed
by a company Farris innovations their
product is called tell assurance and we
selected that not because of any
financial incentives or any ties to that
company in fact we paid for use of that
telemonitoring package but because it's
a device free system and it doesn't
require any reading by patients all of
the questions are just heard over the
phone and so that removes any barriers
that patients might have around literacy
or vision so all of our sites received
support and training from the Yale
coordinating center we went out and
visited each of these practice sites at
the time that they came on to the study
and we several times a year had
conference calls where all of the site
coordinators participated talked about
how it was that they were identifying
patients and rolling patients how were
they screening any challenges that they
had managing the data we paid the site's
slightly more for telemonitoring given
the increased time burden of managing
that information so the telemonitoring
intervention again this consisted of
daily toll free calls to an interactive
voice response system for six months
patients heard questions about their
general health about heart failure
symptoms and about body weight in every
30 days they also rotate it in 2
questions about depressive symptoms from
the phq to so there were predetermined
responses that triggered variances to
flag clinicians attention so you know
for the question of are you having more
shortness of breath in the last day of a
patient answered yes that would trigger
what we call two variants so these
variances are things that might signal
to the clinician that the patient was
getting into trouble so let's dial the
specific questions here just to read
through these quickly to give you a
sense of the real content of this so
compared with yesterday would you say
that you're feeling better the same
worse or much worse have you felt more
short of breath in the last day have you
noticed more swelling in the last day
did you wake up short of breath last
night did you sleep in a chair with more
pillows last night have you had any
dizziness in the last day and then the
depressive symptoms questions are listed
there those are rotated in every 30 days
as I said and then finally patients
enter their weight using a telephone
keypad patients did have to have a
touch-tone telephone we were surprised
at how many patients actually still had
the old rotary phones but we were able
to provide those to patients who needed
them as well so clinicians role in this
was that they had to review the
telemonitoring data every business day
so this meant monday through friday we
weren't expecting physicians to review
this data on weekends or on holidays you
know basically this was sort of part of
their office practice our protocol
required that the clinicians contact
participants whose data indicated
worsening clinical status so those are
the variances that I mentioned earlier
and they actually had to document their
responses right in the telemonitoring
website and i'll show you a screenshot
of what that look like in a minute so
typically this review of the
telemonitoring data was done by nurses
who typically manage this data
independently they could obtain
physician input if they need it
depending on what it was that was going
on with a patient sort of the severity
and patient individual clinical
circumstances but typically these are
pretty high-functioning mid-level
practitioners who oftentimes had
protocols for diuretics and this sort of
thing according to amount of waking or
their symptoms that were going on so
this is a screenshot from the Pharaohs
website and you can see this is
basically what it would look like when
the site coordinator the nurse reviewing
the telemonitoring data would log in in
the morning so they would see a list of
their patients at the top who had
variances so we tried to sort of
organize it in a way that would be
efficient for them to review they listed
exactly what the variance was triggered
by in the next column and then the site
coordinator had to go in and sort of
enter in information about what they did
and then also write a free text note so
similar to what you would expect to
happen in an office around management of
any other sort of clinical situation so
we had a number of strategies to promote
adherence to our protocol so
patience they were told that their
information would be reviewed by the
clinicians who were responsible for
managing their heart failure so they
knew that this is to help your doctors
keep you out of the hospital remember
these are all patients who are recently
hospitalized for heart failure and so
our hope is that they would be highly
incentivized highly motivated to use
this system to sort of be even more
connected with their doctor and help
their doctor take the best possible care
of them if the patient's didn't use the
system for two consecutive days then
they received a system-generated
reminder call just an automated call
from the tell monitoring system after
that if they still didn't use the system
then they got contacted by staff by a
live person from the telemonitoring
company to encourage participation and
these staff members were typically
trained as social workers who were very
well worth versed in behavioral change
and could address the barriers and
challenges that patients might have been
experiencing that might have prevented
them from calling so we had a number of
strategies as well to promote adherence
to the protocol for our clinicians of
course remember these are busy you know
cardiology practices who already have a
very full caseload and now they're using
this telemonitoring sort of on top of
everything else so every two to three
weeks the staff from the coordinating
center reviewed their responses to these
variances and we contacted sites if
there was no documentation of how the
variance was managed in order to ensure
that they were looking at the
information and you know typically it
was a matter if there was no
documentation the website typically it
was a matter of you know the nurse told
us yes yes we saw that but we sort of
just didn't get into the system yet to
document it but we sort of kept a close
eye on that every couple of weeks to
make sure that the information was being
looked at was being acted upon so to
give you a sense of the kinds of things
that clinicians were documenting in the
website is provided a couple of examples
here so this is a nurse who contacted a
patient and her note says that the
patient stated he had been eating smoked
turkey sandwiches along with other
high-salt foods encouraged to watch
dietary intake patient denies any
shortness of breath or dis Mia patient
will call with any change in symptoms
so the baseline characteristics of our
two groups are shown here so we enroll
just over one thousand six hundred forty
patients we had 826 who are randomized
to tell monitoring and 827 who are
randomized to usual care so these are
all their characteristics at baseline
the two groups were very well matched
there were no statistically significant
differences our median age was 61 which
is slightly younger than the average
patient with heart failure and may say
something about the kinds of patients
who are willing to use these sorts of
technologies forty-four percent were
female we had good minority
representation you know NIH requires us
to have at least twenty-five percent
minorities most of our minorities or
black race we had close to forty percent
good socio-economic diversities while a
quarter had less than a high school
education almost thirty percent had an
annual income of less than 10,000 and
you know these were sick patients I've
shown you the most prevalent comorbid
diseases here chronic kidney disease
diabetes and coronary artery disease
that were present in almost half of the
participants you know so these aren't
the sort of clean perfect heart failure
only patients that we oftentimes see in
clinical trials of patients with heart
failure and the two groups were very
similar very well matched also in terms
of their use of medications the heart
failure medications that we would expect
patients to be on so ace inhibitors beta
blockers diuretics into jocks and so you
know in any trial it's important to
understand kind of how much of the dose
was delivered and so we look carefully
at our adherence in many different ways
and and thought a lot about how best to
define adherence and that was really a
challenging question for us so i should
say eighty-six percent of patients who
were randomized to tell a monitoring
made at least one phone call and again
you know how one defines adherence to an
intervention like this isn't totally
clear you know people oftentimes will
talk about sort of the crew rate while
seventy percent of the calls were made
over the six-month period we really felt
that it was important to give a measure
that would give a better sense of what
was happening on a weekly basis since we
understand that heart fail
status may change from week to week even
day to day and so we defined it as
making at least three calls per week
somewhere around half the calls per week
and not surprisingly our adherence was
highest at the beginning of the study so
in the first week ninety percent of
patients met good adherence and by the
final week over fifty-five percent were
adherent so our primary endpoint all
calls readmission or death occurred
exactly equally in the two groups
fifty-two percent we had a number of
secondary endpoints as well all cause
readmission death and heart failure
readmission also occurred exactly
equally in the two groups 47-percent
experienced all cause readmission usual
care forty-nine percent telemonitoring
an 11-percent experienced death in the
two groups we included a number of
secondary endpoints I'll just sort of
scroll through these quickly and
reaching the end of my time here with
you but we looked at number of hospital
days number of readmission we looked at
time to event and we didn't see any
differences in any of these secondary
endpoints and I'll just wrap up by
telling you we looked at a number of
subgroup analyses as well to see well
you know perhaps it's not an effective
intervention if you sort of put it out
there in the universe of heart failure
patients but maybe there's a subgroup we
couldn't find anything we looked at age
sex race ejection fraction New York
heart and we couldn't find anything we
looked at a number of site
characteristics as well which I can
elaborate on so we publish this data and
can just tell you very very quickly one
of the criticisms that has come up is
that we should have used a more
sophisticated form of monitoring
technology that just looking at symptoms
and asking patients to weigh themselves
is sort of sort of outmoded and we
should have looked at more physiologic
parameters we should have had
twenty-four seven Manning of this data
by cardiologists ready to respond and
you know sort of fortuitously this is
exactly the study that was published
several months after ours by German
group they enrolled over 700 patients
with heart failure they had patients who
were not just answering questions and
weighing themselves but had EKG strips
coming in on a daily basis they were
checking blood pressure digital
transmission of body weights and their
call centers were man
24 hours a day seven days a week by
cardiologist who were wearing beepers
and can you imagine getting paid by its
silence wait so they were at the ready
and you know these was a group of
patients who were very good about
following directions they had better
adherence rates than ours and it was a
negative study also so I'll wrap up with
that so in conclusion among patients
recently hospitalized for heart failure
telemonitoring didn't improve outcomes
and our results indicate the importance
of a thorough and independent evaluation
of disease management strategies before
widespread adoption